we're often reminded of the problems of
an ageing society and declining birth
rates however it seems good news is on
the horizon and we have one often
overlooked and undervalued group to
thank all the women this week it was
revealed that the number of women having
children over 40 has doubled in the past
20 years with nearly 29,000 and I quote
middle-aged women in England and Wales
having children in 2017 technological
advancements mean women have more
options than ever before and increasing
numbers are choosing to delay motherhood
for when they are more emotionally and
financially capable of caring for a
child this change is also helping to
level the playing field in terms of how
we value women in Western society which
is usually disproportionately on youth
aka
fertility nonetheless as IVF becomes
more commonplace we need legislation to
close the loophole that means long and
short term health impacts on women
undergoing the procedures aren't
monitored so instead of constantly
knocking older women we better start
thanking and protecting them because
when it comes to our future prosperity
they might just be our saving grace we
have a birth rate in this country of
just over 800,000 and there is an
increase as you said of women over 40
having children my wife had our fourth
child in her 40th year and you know that
is now not unusual at all and and how
things have changed you've got to look
back to history my great-grandmother in
India got married when she was 13 and
would have children I've got a 13 year
old daughter and the thought of having
children nine children you know that's
what things were like then going back a
century ago and how things have changed
there is of course the many reasons why
this is happening the technological
advance of course is huge there's
lifestyles is a working part of it but
there is a flip side to it and and the
the medical director of create fertility
professor Gita noggin he's a dear friend
of mine so she she said a reproductive
tourism for older women to go abroad for
donor eggs and come back pregnant is
increasing it can cost the NHS hundreds
of thousands of pounds to deal with
pregnancy and neonatal complications
such as miscarriages preeclampsia
multiple births and stillbirths in these
women the older fathers linked to these
women also have children with a greater
risk of autism and psychiatric
difficulties so there is the negative
side to it but on the whole I think it's
very positive and I think modern
scientific advances have made this more
and more possible and the thing with
just to add to that I totally accept
your point in terms of the health
implications regarding the child but I
also think and this is something that
geet has done a lot of work on you also
need to make sure we're protecting the
mother but you can scan for a lot of
these potential birth defects in
children so the technological
advancements also means that we can help
prevent some of these things to the cars
against are stacked against 40-something
women they're stacked against them
however in in terms of society they're
not because 40-something women have had
a crack at a career there they're
they're more financially mature they
more emotionally mature they're there
they're likely to make more mature
child-rearing decisions and an
interesting era some of the deaths said
you know women in their forties are more
likely to breastfeed than younger woman
so actually that's great for the child
too my only worry is that some women
have to wait on their 40 in a better
world women would have social supports
to make decisions for career building
and and and you know and family building
in a way that men do but but then the
choice would be to have the choice when
to have kids would be a true choice then
but that's not happen and that's what I
fear about older women that they feel
they have to work to a certain age but
what about you you're 41 I am what about
you so that means I'm gonna be
middle-aged mom is my
would you have a child alone Oh child
alone not me and I'm not against anybody
who would you know Michelle and I've had
this debate many times on the show I
personally would not do it without a
secure partnership now so if you didn't
meet someone the apart you wouldn't
there are lots of ways to be a mother I
have to have believe you know going work
in an orphanage there's lots of can I
just say no one celebrates were in their
forties
in fact I celebrate this often I carry
one currently and I'm very happy
celebrating a woman in her forties and
it doesn't fall to anyone let alone a
man to tell a woman when she should have
a child all I would say is I'm surprised
it's not come up yet and if you want to
have a baby when you're 41 for you good
luck sure and I hope it goes well bear
in mind because of the brilliance of our
clinicians and doctors it's likely that
your mum and dad are going to be around
a lot longer so you're going to find
yourself looking after mum and dad who
could be in their 60s and 70s and
suddenly you're going to have one maybe
two babies so you are going to have and
if that's what you want well done but
we're what you will be in the trap
you'll be looking after mum and dad
possibly increasing frail health little
baby maybe two Man Alive you will need
the stammer of Olympic athlete when I
was in my 20s my mother said you know
there's never a good time to have a baby
and I ended up having three and my 20
and combining it with full-time work at
that point yes I'm proud to call this
baby days that's what you could afford
that restaurant and there is no getting
around it it is a slog it is a snog and
also you are doing it at a time when
you're supposed to be establishing
yourself in your own career so there is
at the upside of doing at age 40 plus is
you have hopefully establish your career
you can take time out six months out of
the office make you make the dad to take
over the Paterno do the further six
months now we've got a paternity leave
that men do not take advantage of I mean
they're a
of taking a fatality because pay
disparity though there's other reasons
that's why men do but the downside is
can I just mention a couple of downsides
you know mother nature you cannot beat
the clock and if you have your babies in
your 20s I'm very much against children
having children got that stomach turns
at that thought but if you have men your
twenties you have the energy knowing
what you know now do you wish you'd
waited would you know no I throw that
meaning my children and our adults and
there's another point building on what
you've just said is that if you if you
start having children when you're 40
then if you want to have three four
children it makes it yeah much more
difficult yes you're more likely to have
multiple births when you're older that's
all - now the nature has a way of fixing
we must mention the fact that if you
can't conceive naturally the the rate of
IVF can successful conception is only
about eighteen seventeen percent yeah
and that's very not great so if you know
you are you're dicing every year yeah
and I would I wouldn't be surprised if
that increases significantly in the
years to come